et
[Musique]
moi
joker
bon vent
[Musique]
et tu fais quoi ici à summer ville bah
en fait mais on veut pas le dire mais on
n'a plus d'argent tout ce qui nous reste
c'est une vieille ferme flippante que
mon grand père nous a laissé en pleine
cambrousse
ah d'accord c'est encore plus pourri que
ce que je pensais
j'ai trouvé ça dans mon salon où c'est
une superbe copier une copie de quoi
d'un piège à fantômes
[Musique]
on n'a pas signalé de fantôme depuis 30
ans
new york dans les années 80 c'était
comme the walking dead ton père tu en a
jamais parlé j'ai que ma mère
mon grand père est mort
pour ma mère on est là pour trier tous
les vieux trucs qu'il a laissé
[Musique]
à temps
elle qui est dieu
fatalité
chance ou câble
tout arrive pour une bonne raison
allez ma belle
yann battard tillard
moi c'est pas croyable j'ai jamais rien
vu d'aussi cool